ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูเอ๋สวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะเรียนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียน
ครูเอ๋วันนี้วันอะไรคะวันนี้วันเสาร์ค่ะ
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 20 ไหมคะ 20  11
ราคาหน้าวันที่ขอโทษครูเอ๋ลืมไม่เป็นไร
ค่ะ 21 ค่ะเดือนอะไรคะเดือน
พฤษภาคม
ปีพตอะไรคะต้องคันค่าร้อย 65
เวลาที่ครูเอ๋รออยู่ดีคศอะไรคะต้องพัน 22
the  game  a  22
ขนาดแล้วกี่โมงแล้วคะตอนนี้ครูเอ๋ตอนนี้
นะคะตอนนี้เวลา
[เพลง]
15:00 น
ค่า 15 นาที
รอบ่าย 3 โมง 55 นาทีนก็เป็นตอนกลางวันนะ
คะบ่ายๆยังร้อนร้อนใจค่ะน่าจะประมาณสัก 4
18 องศาเซลเซียสนั้นเธอถึงจะรักกูอูเอะ
อะ
35 รัก 35  35 ราคา 35
โอเคค่ะคุณหนิงหยุดแชร์แล้วค่ะครูเอ๋
เสร็จแล้วคลิปนี้กูเอกก็ยังมีรูป
Heart  2 ไส้ไหมให้ครูเอกชอบ mir อ๋อ
ค่ะได้ค่ะมากๆนะคะนักเรียนเบาะหา
นักเรียนออกไม่เป็นไรผู้หญิงคิดนะคะไม่
เป็นไรเนาะดูรูปคะฟังภาษาไทย
โอเค
ไม่เอารูปนี้ครูเอ๋กำลัง Share  screen
วิมาแล้วมาแล้วนะคะๆผู้หญิงคะคะรู๋
มีคำถามผู้หญิงใต้ค่ะอะไรคะผู้หญิงเห็น
อ้าว
น้ำน้ำอะไรคะน้ำทะเลเหรอ
ถ้า
ผู้หญิงเก่งอยู่ใช่ไหมทำไมรู้เข็นแค่นี้
รู้เป็นทะเลผู้หญิงกับผู้เอกไปด้วยคะ
แล้วก็เห็นอะไรคะอันนี้ดวงอาทิตย์ค่ะดวง
อาทิตย์เห็นอะไรคะ
นก
นกนะคะผู้หญิงนกกำลังทำอะไรคะนกกำลังบิน
ตกกำลังบินนะคะภายขนาดนกกำลังบินแล้วดวง
อาทิตย์กำลัง
ดวงอาทิตย์กำลังจะตกอ่ะกำลังจะตกนะไก่ค่ะ
กำลังจะตบแย่งยังค่ะกำลังจะตกกำลังจะตก
แล้วก็เปลี่ยนเป็นกลางคืนใช่ไหมคะดู
อาทิตย์ตกสวยเนาะสวยมากสวยมากๆอิ่มนก
กำลังบินแล้วนกตรงนี้กำลังทำอะไร
กำลังทำถ้าใครเค้าครูเอ๋นกกำลังว่ายน้ำ
หรอออใช่ทรายค่ะนกตัวนี้เนี่ย
กำลังว่ายน้ำ
ใช่นกตัวนี้นะคะนักเรียนบินได้ว่ายน้ำได้
ครูเอ๋รู้ไหมนกชื่ออะไรนกนางนวลอ่านกแดง
นวลเนี่ยบินได้ว่ายน้ำได้ๆนะคะอ้องั้นภาพ
นี้ภาพนี้นักเรียนก็เห็นพระอาทิตย์กำลัง
จะตกอ่ะ
แล้วก็นกกำลังบินนะคะนกกำลัง
ว่ายนาง
โอเค f ต่อไปผู้หญิงอ่ะ
แอบ
ดูอะไรคะครูเอ๋ขยายใหญ่ๆได้มั้ย
ได้ค่ะ
ตัวกระรอกค่ะเห็นไหมอ่ะหิวหัดกระรอกตัว
นี้นะกรอบตัวกระรอกนะคะ
ที่คอนโด
ดีจริงๆเลยค่ะตัวเองที่นี่ค่ะครูหญิงตัว
กระรอกกำลังทำอะไรคะรูปไหนคะ
เอารูปนี้ก่อนก็ได้ค่ะ
นิดคุก Mini ให้พูดเองรูปแรกค่ะกะร้อง
กำลังทำอะไรอยู่เหรอคะพี่กำลังวิ่งวิ่ง
กำลังวิ่งแล้วรูปนี้ล่ะคะครูหญิงการอ๊
กำลังลงจากต้นไม้ขอ
ไอวิ่งแล้วก็ขึ้นต้นไม้แล้วก็ปีนลงจากต้น
ไม้นะฮะไม่มีระบบปีนไม่ก็ลองปีนปีนต้นไม้
แล้ววิ่งมันวิ่งขึ้นต้นไม้วิ่งลงอย่าง
วิ่งขึ้นวิ่งลงแต่ถ้าขึ้นอะไรสูงๆเราก็
พูดแล้วปีนใช่ไหมจ่ายค่ะวิ่งปีนขึ้นต้น
ไม้ปีนลงต้นไม้ตายวางจะเกาะเกาะนี่น่ารัก
ๆเพื่อนครูเอ๋ให้
น่ารักอ่ะมีของกินปูมีอะไรบ้างคะครูเอ๋
มีปีกไก่ไก่ไก่
มีตับไก่นะคะแล้วก็มีของคนค่ะ
และทีมนะคะอ่ะคีมสำหรับคีบนะคะผู้หญิงคะ
ครูเอ๋มีคำถามได้ค่ะครูเอ๋
อันนี้ผู้ชายนะคะผู้ชายผู้หญิงนึกว่าผู้
หญิงตอนแรกผู้ชายผู้ชายอักเสบคอยาวอ่า
ผู้ชายคนเนี้ยกำลังทำอะไรคะ
กำลัง
ย่างก็ยังไก่
กำลังย่างไก่เขามือเข้าจับครีมคีบไก่แล้ว
ก็พริกใช่มะถึง
แล้วบอกกำลังย่างไก่เนาะจ่ายค่ะกำลังย่า
ต้องดูแล้วก็ย่างพริกไก่อ่ากำลังคลิปไก่
ก็ได้กำลังยากไก่ได้
โอเคต่อไปต่อไปอันนี้ต่อไปเกาะเต่าหญ้าโห
ผู้หญิงงงใช่ไหมคะใช่ค่ะผู้หญิงเห็นผู้
ชายผู้ชายใช่ไหมคะสองคนที่เซ็กซี่
ผู้หญิงอยากไปดูผู้ชายสองคนอยู่ที่ไหนคะ
S ค่ะในห้องน้ำงานในห้องน้ำนะคะผู้ชาย
สองคนนี้เราเรียกว่าช่างห่าเอา
ช่างกำลังทำอะไรคะกำลังส้มห้องน้ำเหรอคะ
ใช่ค่ะ
ห้องน้ำไม่ดีช่างกำลังซ่อม
กำลังกำลังเอาออกพูดว่าซ่อมห้องน้ำค่ะอ๋อ
อ๋อเสร็จห้องน้ำก็ดีเหมือนเดิมเลยใช่
เราไป
คุณยาย
ผู้หญิงแก่เรียกคุณยาย
แก่สวยค่ะดูเสื้อหลานดูแฟชั่นใช่ไหมดู
เสื้อเสื้อสีม่วงเนี่ย
แก่เสื้ออะไรคะเสื้อคอกระเช้าค่ะสีม่วง
เช้าแล้วใส่อะไรคะข้างล่างเขานุ่งเนี่ย
หรอคะส่งกระเบนใช่ไหมคะนายค่ะ
คุณยายคุณยายชื่ออะไรคะคุณยายเอ๋ยายเอ๋
คุณยายเอกกำลังทำอะไรคะมันทำอะไรคะกำลัง
ยืนยืนที่มือขอกราบคุณยายเอ๋กำลังจับอะไร
คะกลับไม้เท้าค่ะอันนี้อันนี้นะคะนัก
เรียน
นิ
จ้า
อ๋อคุณยายกำลังยืนจับไม้เท้าเหรอคะ I ค่ะ
หรือยืนถือไม้เท้าถือหรือจับปลาได้นะคะ
อ่ะไม้เท้าไม่เป็นมองเห็นไหมเนี้ย
ไม่เท้าสีเหมือนทรงกระเบนไงสีคล้ายๆให้
รัฐบาลนักเรียนสี
สีฟ้าก็ได้ค่ะไม้เท้าอันนี้เนาะ
ไม้เท้านะฮะคุณยายเอ๋กำลังจับไม้เท้านะคะ
โอเคต่อไปค่ะวันนี้สวย
ว้านายปลา
สีฟ้าใสมากเลย
ปลาอันนี้เป็นปลาที่ญี่ปุ่นนะคะครูเอ๋คะ
ปลาที่อยู่ในรูปเนี่ยจริงๆตัวใหญ่หรือว่า
ตัวเล็กค่ะตัวเล็กค่ะเล็กมากๆเลยคะเท่า
น้ิวคู๋นะคะอ๋อ
ปลาเท่านิ้วผู้หญิงคะปลากำลังทำอะไรคะปลา
กำลังว่ายน้ำค่ะว่ายน้ำ
คิดว่าอร่อยเหมือนกัน
โอเคผู้หญิงกำลังคิดอะไรคะคิดกำลังคิดกิน
เปล่า
กำลังคิดอะไรคิดกินปลาลาทำเมนูอะไรอร่อย
นั้นกำลังคิดกำลังหิวโว้ยหิว
ใจอะรู้จะไป
เต็ม
ที่ทะเลเหรอคะครูเอ๋ให้ค่ะมี
ทะเล
ชายหาดนะคะ
ผู้หญิงเห็นสองคนนี้ไหมคะเห็นค่า
ทำใหญ่ๆดีกว่า
[เพลง]
ไหม
เพราะเห็นชัดขึ้นแล้วค่ะหน้า
สองคนนี้กำลังทำอะไรคะผู้หญิงกำลังนั่ง
อ่ากำลังนั่งนะคะกำลังนั่งแล้วก็เล่นเล่น
ทรายเล่นสนะคาชายหาดเนี่ยมีทราย
ตัวเองจะขยายใหญ่ให้อีกนะค่ะโอเคนะนะถ้า
หน้าสองคนกำลังเล่นมีอายนะคะ
โอเคต่อไปนะคะลูกต่อไปค่ะครูดีโห้
ผู้หญิงเห็นอะไร
ครูหญิงเห็นต้นไม้
เห็นใบไม้
แล้วก็เห็นอะไรอีกดวงอาทิตย์หรอนายดวง
อาทิตย์พระอาทิตย์โอเคค่ากำลังอะไรคะ
กำลังส่องแสงชายเก่งมาก
แต่ปลานะครับพระอาทิตย์นะคะนักเรียนตรง
นี้แสงบุหรี่
แต่ตัวเองขยับแป๊บนึงอ่ะ
อันนี้เป็นแสงค่ะใช่เห็นไม่เห็นด้วยแสง
พระอาทิตย์ 5 เรา
ก็บอกว่าพระอาทิตย์กำลังส่องแสงนะค่ะ 2
อาจเจ็บตาสวย
สวยค่ะขอบคุณค่ะครูเอ๋ถ่ายแล้วตา OK ไหม
เสร็จแล้วโอเค
มีอีกไหมคะครูเอ๋มีค่ะครูหญิงผู้หญิงมี
รูปเยอะ
อ๋อ
หัวพระอาทิตย์กำลังตกนะคะตอบว่าที่กำลัง
ตก
อันนี้ก็ไม่เอาอ้าอันนี้ดีกว่า
ครูหญิงเห็นดอกไม้สีขาวค่ะหน้าดอกไม้สี
ขาวกำลังเป็นอะไรคะกำลังบานเหรอคะใช่ค่ะ
โอ๋โอ้ยเก่งมากเอานี่ไงครูหญิงคุยเห็นดอก
นี้นี้ว่ามันหุบบับตูมตูมตูมเบิก 6
ตูมตูมนักเรียน
ตูบเข้า 6 เนี่ยคือบ้านแล้วก็ 6 แล้วก็
บ้านแล้วก็อก
ผู้หญิงต้องพูดว่าดอกนี้ยังขุกอยู่
ก็เลยเพราะเห็นดอกนี้ก็เลยคิดเอามันกำลัง
Bar กำลังมาใช่ค่ะกำลังคุกเกาะคุกอยู่
โอเค
จิ้มเป็นดอกตูม
ดอกไม้อีกดอกหนึ่งค่ะดอกอะไรคะดอกบัวค่ะ
ดอกบัวจำลังอะไรคะดอกบัวกำลังบานไหมคะให้
ค่ะกำลังบานผู้หญิงค่ะดอกบัวเนี่ยค่ะบ้าน
แล้วก็ขุบแล้วก็บานแล้วก็ 6 เอา
งู
แต่ดอกดอกไม้ดอกที่แล้วถ้าบานอันนี้ไม่
หุบไม่ 6 จะบานบานบานแล้วก็รวงแล้วก็หมด
ไม่มีดอกไม้มายภาพบอกดอกบัวแบบนี้ค่ะมี
บานแล้วก็มีคุกนะคะบ้าน 6 บานคุปต์แล้วก็
ร่วงเวทแล้วเขียวเขียวอันนี้อะไรคะใบบัว
ค่ะเอามีดอกบัวแล้วก็มีใบบัวผู้หญิงสี
เหลืองอะไรสีเหลืองเกสรหรอคะใช่ค่ะ
เกสรดอกไม้เกสรดอกบัวอันนิดดอกบัวนะคะนัก
เรียนอันนี้อะไรนะคะ
กรีบบัว
อันนี้อะไรคะ
เกสรดอกบัว
เกสรดอกบัวนะคะอ่ะฮะโอเค
นี้มีอีกไหมคะครูเองหนู
ไม่เอา
คนกำลังทำอะไรคะผู้หญิง
กำลังเดินกี่คนนะ 2 คนค่ะสองคนกำลังเดิน
กำลังเดินนะคะต่อไป
อันนี้ก่อน
ผู้หญิงคิดใช่ขาดคิดว่าอะไรที่ท่านควรถนน
หน้ามีอะไรเยอะๆคะมีรสค่ะมีรถมีรถเยอะๆรถ
กำลังอะไรคะผู้หญิง
กำลังติดค่ะรถกำลังติดนะคะแล่นไม่ได้
ไปไม่ได้
ถ้ากูเองเบอร์โทรศัพท์ผู้หญิงผู้หญิงที่
ถนนยังไงโอที่ถนนตอนนี้รถกำลังติดเลย
งั้นครูเอไป BTS เนาะได้ดีกว่ารถกำลังติด
มากๆไปไม่ได้ไปทักซี่ไม่โอเคค่ะไปเอากิน
ka ไป BTS นะคะดีกว่าเพราะว่ารถกำลังติด
หรือบางทีครูเอ้อยู่ที่บ้านรอกูหญิงมาผู้
หญิงค่ะอยู่ครูหญิงอยู่ที่ไหนอยู่บนถนน
อ้าวทำไมช้า Go ตอนนี้รถกำลังติดมากๆหรอ
ครูไม่เห็น
ตอนครูหญิงอยู่ถนนที่ถนนครูหญิงเนี่ยรถ
กำลังติดกู AU ที่บ้านรถไม่ติดตัวเองออก
มาดีสนน
โอเคมั้ยไป
ฮะ
โอเคนะกรุงเทพแล้วเฮ้ย
ไปสภาพต่อไปเนาะภาพต่อไปค่ะครูเอ๋กู
สวยไหมคะผู้หญิงอุ้ยสวยค่ะผู้หญิงเห็นมา
นั่งเหรอคะไม่ได้เห็นมานานอ่ะอ่าผู้หญิง
ชี้ใหม่
อันนี้นะคะ
มานางแล้วก็ก็ดอกซากุระค่ะ
นะคะผู้หญิงอ่ะครูเอจะถามอะไรขับได้รูป
นี้ผู้หญิงรู้แล้ว
กูยังไม่ถามโอเคขอเพลงแล้วดอกซากุระทำ
กำลังอะไรคะผู้หญิงดอกซากุระกำลังร่วงทอง
ค่ะ
สะกุระกำลังร่วงไม่ใช่ปลานะคะนักเรียนไม่
ใช่
บ้านเสร็จแล้วและก็
รวงที่กำลังร่วงนะคะโรย
สวยค่ะครูเอ๋
โอเค
อะไรคะครูเอ๋
ดอกไม้ไฟ
ดอกไม้ไฟนะคะค่ะมันห้างล่ะดอกไม้ไฟคู่
หญิงโอเคนะมองเห็นนะคะมองเห็นค่ะบางทีพูด
พรุ
บางทีพูดดอกไม้ไฟดอกไม้ไฟนะเวลาจุดแล้วก็
วิ่ง
กำลังอะไรคะ
แฟน
นี่บอกกำลังคิดอยู่เลยนะว่าอยู่ออกมาที่
อยู่มันอะไรอ่ะ
ผู้หญิงกำลังโกรธครูเอ๋
ใส่
บานก็ไม่ใช่
เปิด
ระเบิดเค้าไม่ใช่แต่แตกฮะ
เวลาจุดดอกไม้ไฟจะพุ่งขึ้นไปมุงเราก็แตก
กระจาย
อ่อน
แตกแล้วก็กระจายไม่พูดระเบิดเนาะระเบิด
ให้พูดมันจะใบบูสะเกรงนั้นในรูปนี้ดอกไม้
ไฟก็กำลังแตกกระจายอยู่บนฟ้า
จานจ่ายแล้วก็ร่วงนะคะถ้า
กูใจดำไม่ผู้หญิงชายค่ะมีอีกไหมคะมีรูป
อีกไหมคะมีค่าหนู
โอเคผู้หญิงเห็นอะไรติดตั้งคะ
ช้างค่ะค่ะคริเห็นช้าง
เห็นช้างหลายๆที่เชื่อเมื่อแล้วคุยค่ะอัน
นี้อะไรคะผู้หญิง
กะเหรี่ยงหรอไอข่าสเลียงอันนี้อะไรคะ
ร่มร่มเบอร์กันคิดอะไรอะไรร่มเออจริงๆ
ร่วมแบบนี้เรียกฉัตรก็ได้แต่สำหรับคุณ
เล็กฉัตรเรียกขาร่มนะคะร่ม
แล้วก็คนนี้เรียกว่าอะไรคะควาญช้างค่ะมัน
ช้างตรงนี้เลขอะไรของช้างคะ
งาช้าง
โอเคคำถาม
นะคะคำถามคือ
ห้ามเท่าไหร่คะครูเอ๋อามว่าผู้หญิงคนนี้
กำลังทำอะไรเธอ
คนนี้คนที่
กำลังทำอะไรกำลังนั่งช้างเก่งมาก
กำลังด้านช้างค่ะชอบนั่งช้างไหมคะครูหญิง
มั้ยเคยออกไม่เคยไม่เคยคิดจะนั่งช้างไหม
คะ
ไม่คิด
กลัวเหรอคะ
ฟังคนที่เคยนั่งช้างบอกเลยเฮ้อมันอ่า
ได้เวียนหัวก็เลยคิดไม่คิดนั่งช้างค่ะบาง
คนตื่นเต้นใช่มั้ยเย้ครูเอ๋ไม่ชอบไม่เอ๋
เคยนั่งใช่ไหมคะ 2 ครั้งค่ะแล้วก็ไม่ชอบ
นะจุ๊บๆๆๆ
ผู้หญิงก็ฟังครูเอ๋
ไม่นักเรียนนักเรียนบอกยิ่ง
น่า
นั่งช้าง
ครูเอ๋เอ๋แล้วคนนี้ขวานช้างเนี่ยนั่งช้าง
ไหมคะวันนางค่ะแต่เขาเล็กไสช้างอ้าวหรอขอ
ให้ช้างไปค่ะความช้างต้องช้างไปไปอะนะ
ไสช้างค่ะ
มีอีกนะคะ
ปีหน้าคุณคุณนะคะโอเคในสวนอีกแล้วเหรอคะ
ครูเอ๋สวนในสวนนะคะอ่ะ
ไม่เป็นไรรูปนี้ไม่เอาผู้ชายกำลังยืนนะ
หาง
ยืนพิงต้นไม้
ใช้ยืนพิงนะคะแบบเขาจะเธอยืนพิงต้นไม้
แล้วมือเขากำลังทำอะไรคะ
กอดโอเคตอนแรกทักครูเอ๋ถามครูหญิงจะบอก
ว่าผู้ชายคนนี้กำลังยืนหลับ
ไม่เล่าผู้ชายกำลังยืนก่อนจบแล้วก็
ขอ
คนที่บ้านค่ะค่ะเอาปลามีรูปอีกไหมคะอุ้ย
เกรดรวม
anti-a อ่ะคะครูเอ๋ล่ะไม่ใช่ในรูปเนี่ย
โรแมนติกค่ะอ๋อครูเอ๋เอ๋
ผู้หญิงคะครูเอ๋เนี่ย
กัมมี่มีครูเอ๋แล้วมีอะไรคะหมาค่ะหมาหมา
กำลังทำน้อง
หมากำลังยมครูเอ๋
นี่ไงผู้หญิงดูนี่ที่นี่ใช่ไหมจมูกสมุป
หมามันกำลังดมครูเอ๋ค่ะหมากำลังดมคู๋
เสร็จแล้วหมาก็เลียนั่ง
หมาใครไม่รู้ไว้
เรียนอ้าหวยค่ะ
โอเค
มีอีกไหมคะครูเอ๋มีมีๆครูเอ๋กำลังหาอยู่
ค่ะได้นักเรียนรู้หมาก่อนกู
คุยดี
มีถนนค่ะผู้หญิงเห็นตรงนี้ไหมอ่ะเนี่ยคะ
ใช่
ที่เห็นคะค่ะเห็นนะคะมีคนกี่คนคะ
มีคน 1  2  3  4  4 คนไหมคะโง่สิคนโอเค
สามคนเนี้ยเอาตรงนี้ 3 คอร์ดอันนี้ไม่เอา
ไม่เอากำลังทำอะไรคะกำลังปั่นจักรยานค่ะ
เก่งมากแล้วก็เราหมด
จักรยานนักเรียนเห็นไหมเดี๋ยวกูเอกขยาย
จ่ายค่ะ
ขยายใหญ่ๆโอเค 3 คนกำลังปั่นจักรยาน
ใส่ค่ะคุยให้ดูวิวนะคนเล็กๆ
นักเรียนต้องแบบ
อะไรดีๆ
อ่ะต่อไปค่ะครูหญิงหู
งานแต่งงานอาเย้
มีเค้ก
มีเค้กมีค่ะมีอันนี้คนนี้เรียกว่าอะไรคะ
เจ้าบ่าววันนี้เรียกว่าอะไรคะเจ้าสาวตรง
นี้อะไรคะเนี่ยเทียนค่ะเขียนนะคะอันนี้
อะไรคะ
มีดหรอเอ๋ให้ค่ะมีมีดมีผู้หญิงคะเจ้าบ่าว
กับเจ้าสาวกำลังทำอะไรคะกำลังตัดเค้กค่ะ
กำลังตัดเค้ก
อร่อย
อร่อยนะผู้หญิงไม่ได้กินครับกูเอง
คิดว่าเจ้าบ่าวเจ้าสาวหล่อแล้วก็สวยนะคะ
คิดว่าเจ้าบ่าวหล่อหล่อค่ะอาพี่น้องสาวนะ
คะสวยเขาโอเคโอเค
เดี๋ยวดูดีกว่าไหมคะจุ๊ xxx ดูไหม
ไม่ดูนะคะเอ๊ยดูผู้หญิงในงานแต่งงานครู
หญิงจำว่าแตงโมอร่อยค่ะครูเอ๋
ผู้หญิงรู้จักงานแต่งงานนี้
พี่น่าจะพาผู้หญิงไปค่ะผู้หญิงไม่รู้เค้ก
อร่อยไม่อร่อยไม่รู้แต่แตงโมอร่อยค่ะ
ไม่รู้เค้กอร่อยไว้อร่อยไม่กินนะคะฉันที่
คอผู้หญิงที่คอเจ้าบ่าวมีอะไรคะมีพวง
มาลัยค่ะพวงมาลัยนะคะ
ต่อไปค่ะพูดนี้มีขอรูปงานแต่งงานอีกไหมคะ
ทำไมคะ
ผู้หญิงอยากดู
ไงโอเค
ผู้หญิงเห็นงานแต่งงานเหมือนกันนะคะคำถาม
คือเด็กๆทุกคนตรงนี้ทำอะไร
กำลังเต้นค่ะ
กำลังเต้นไม่รู้ก็ได้เข้าใจแล้วว่าเต้น
ไม่เก่ง
สองคนไม่เต้นนะเฟคทั้งคนนี้คนนี้กำลัง
ถ่ายรูปไหมเนี่ย
ใช่ตาดี
กำลังถ่ายรูปนะกำลังถ่ายรูปแต่ 2 เด็ก 2
คนเนี่ยกำลังเต้นนะคะเต้นนะ
กูเองมีรูปนี้ลูกนี้หนูครูเอ๋
หมอ
ผีผี
ตาโขน
ผู้หญิงคะผู้หญิงคนนี้นี้
ใช่ไหมคะค่ะผู้หญิงคนนี้อ่ะไม่รู้จะเอาสี
อะไรพ่อสีเยอะผู้หญิงคนนี้นะเอาเขตคนนี้
น่ะอ้ะค่ะ
[เพลง]
กำลังเต้นใช่ไหมคะไม่ใช่ค่ะครูเอ๋ไม่ได้
เต้นเหรอคะไม่ได้เต้นผู้หญิงคนนี้ไม่ใช่
ไม่ได้กำลังเต้นแล้วเขากำลังทำอะไรคะ
กำลังรำค่ะรำกำลังน้อยๆหน้านี้นะน้อยน้อย
ๆเราก็ปิดได้
จ่ายค่ะเขาคือผู้หญิงเองค่ะไม่ใช่
ผู้หญิงรำสวย XXX เราเปิดหน้าเดี๋ยวเขาจะ
ตีเราเราก็เลยต้องเขากำลังทำค่ะครูเอ๋ไม่
ใช่เต้น
กำลังขออีก 1 รูปก่อนหมดเวลาโอเคไหนมีค่ะ
ทำไมเยอะจังเลย
ผู้หญิงอยากได้รูปอะไรตัวเองมี 2 ลูก
เดี๋ยวให้เอารูปนี้ก่อนนะคะพรุ่งนี้
มีอะไรบ้างมีนักมีข้าวนาข้าวมีต่อไม้มี
อะไรคะป่าค่ะแล้วก็อะไรคะงัวเหรอคะหมอ
ผู้หญิงวัวกำลังทำอะไรกินหญ้า
เก็บไว้ที่
คิดตั้งนาน
วัวกินหญ้า
ami มีอีกหลายรูปเลยอยากให้ดูอ่ะอ่ะ
พี่ปุ้ยลิงเหรอคะครูเอ๋นี่ลิงลิงกำลังทำ
อะไรคะผู้หญิงยิงกำลังชอบน้ำเมื่อยกำลัง
แช่น้ำร้อน
สว่างกำลังแช่น้ำเคมีอีกรูปให้ดูหรอคะ
อุ้ยมีอีกค่ะมีเยอะค่ะ
ฮะผู้หญิง
ผู้หญิงอันเนี้ยลูกบ๊วยนะคะ
แล้วอันนี้เป็นน้ำบ๊วย
น้ำบ๊วยแล้วเราใส่น้ำแข็ง
ใส่น้ำแข็งอ่ะตอนนี้น้ำบ๊วยกำลังอะไรคะ
กำลังเย็น
เก่งมากค่ะใส่น้ำแข็งแล้วมันจะเย็นไง
นักเรียนเห็นนะดูแล้วจะรู้เลยว่ากำลัง
เย็นนะเย็นเนื้อรักศัพท์ก็คือถ้ามันเย็น
คู๋ให้ดูใหญ่ๆนะ
น้องนี่ไงมีน้ำข้างนอกทำไมมันเย็นเห็นไหม
ผู้หญิงเห็นนะเห็นค่ะเห็นค่ะเห็นตรงนี้
นี่ตรงนี้ตรงนี้กำลังเย็นนะกำลังเย็นค่ะ
เย็นเลย
จ่ายโอเคหมดเวลาใช่ไหมผู้หญิงชายค่ะหมด
เวลาแล้วหนอนักเรียนเนี่ยกำลังทำอะไรอยู่
คะนักเรียนกำลังปวดหัว
น้องนักเรียนบอกว่ากำลังดูวีดีโอนี้
กำลังชอบกำลังปวดหัวกำลังหิวเออนะไม่รู้
นั้นแต่ว่าวีดีโอนี้หมดเวลาแล้วน้องผู้
หญิงกับครูเอ๋ก็ต้องไปก่อนนะคะ
คะเดี๋ยวเจอกันวีดีโอหน้านะคะสวัสดีค่ะ
บ๊ายบาย
[เพลง]